so hi everyone i'm really excited to be
able to share with you today the work
we've been doing at congenica
and providing a rapid exome sequencing
service for patients with complex rare
disease
before we begin i'd like to introduce
myself i sit within the congenica
clinical team as a practicing state
registered clinical scientist
i've previously worked within the nhs
and undertook my specialist training at
a major regional genetic center in
london
i'm a member of the bsgm and a former
chair of the london healthcare scientist
training network
i have a specialist interest in
neurodevelopmental disorders and
epilepsy
as a team we've worked collaboratively
with a number of institutions that also
specialize in this area
so future neuro and the institute of
basic research just to name a few
i also have an interest in reproductive
and prenatal genomics um i was due to
present some of this work actually at a
um acmg in march in san antonio but
unfortunately due to the current
situation this was cancelled
the good news is that i believe an
online version of that content should be
available also later this year
so before we begin congenica is a
digital health company helping
healthcare professionals and
organizations to rapidly turn complex
genomic data
into clinically relevant insights that
support diagnosis and clinical decision
making
perhaps some of you might already be
aware but congenica has developed a
clinical decision support platform for
the analysis and interpretation of ngs
panels
exomes and whole genomes although we're
a relatively young business congenica
has a glowing globe um
growing global base of collaborators and
customers including diagnostic labs
research centers and national genomic
programs
a particular note is our partnership
with genomics england in the 100 000
genomes project for rare diseases
as well as the nhs in the rollout of
genomic medicine service to the entire
uk health system
in terms of an outline for today i
really want to begin by outlining the
value
of exome sequencing as a diagnostic
approach for patients with complex rare
disease
i'll then move on to discussing the
rapid exome sequencing service we've
developed with a particular focus on
some real life case studies
so to begin what is the value of exome
sequencing
well in recent years exome sequencing
has been consistently shown to improve
the diagnostic yields when used as an
approach to diagnose children with
suspected monogenic disease
i'd like to draw your attention in
particular too as i'm showing on the
slide this paper from a few years ago by
dylan attell
who found that in a cohort of children
with suspected monogenic disease
23 of the patients that they considered
diagnosed by whole exome sequencing
would have gone undiagnosed by a panel
approach
the value of exome sequencing and
achieving a higher diagnostic yield for
these patients is likely to be even
higher if you can incorporate a copy
number variant element
which we're able to do using our
pipeline and i'll discuss this in much
greater detail later on in the
presentation
incorporating a copy number element
potentially eliminates the need for
acgh mlpa or some other assessment of
copy number
status to be performed and clearly a
number of children particularly with
neurodevelopmental disorders will have a
structural imbalance rather than a
single nucleotide variant or
small indel such like
so there are over 1 500 known
loci known to be associated with
neurodevelopmental disorders
and the mode of inheritance can be
recessive dominant
x-linked and is also complicated by
complex inheritance patterns
and the effect that the environment may
play
the genes identified to be associated
with epilepsy
grow almost daily in particular if we
think about epilepsy as a subset of
those neurodevelopmental disorders
and it's now recognized that for these
conditions a single phenotype can be
caused by
several different genes it's also
recognized that
variants in a single gene can bring
about several different phenotypes
making it really difficult for a
clinician to pinpoint a single gene for
any given phenotype
and what this does is it really
illustrates the need to stratify the
causes further with better genomic
understanding for these conditions
but also the need for a diagnostic
pathway to reflect this high
heterogeneity
and this is where exome sequencing is
clearly a good fit
so if we step back a little bit and
think about in particular so as i've
been talking about neurodevelopmental
disorders
for children presenting with the
neurodevelopmental disorder
the referring clinician will often use a
battery of different diagnostic tests
including both genetic and non-genetic
analyses
a multidisciplinary some mdt approaches
could be needed
involving both clinical and scientific
professionals
genetic testing strategies often include
analysis of whole chromosomes using as
i've mentioned
earlier in the presentation chromosomal
microarray
or sequencing via a gene panel approach
and it can take over six months to
achieve
a diagnosis and so it can take over
six months sorry to to undertake this
diagnostic process
and at the end a diagnosis may still not
be achieved if the causal gene or
mechanism of action
is missing from the analysis undertaken
and if we think about the reasons why
there's such a diagnostic odyssey for
these
patients and why they're often left
without a diagnosis
um the reasons are really as i'm showing
on the slide here numerous and quite
complex
to put it simply the tests aren't
comprehensive enough to pick up every
diagnosis
either because they don't consider the
gene of interest
or the appropriate mechanism of action
so
why is a different testing strategy not
being adopted well
resource allocation can often be an
issue so physicians and scientists don't
have unlimited time
and money to spend searching for a
diagnosis in every single patient
by performing more and more sequential
testing
and it's therefore there are also often
considerations around funding
so what testing is is funded in
different healthcare systems for these
patients
and it can also be hard for physicians
and scientists to find time to keep up
to date
in terms of gene discovery and the
general diagnostic field
and as i've stated here it's really a
hugely fast-paced area of medicine
um so you can you can imagine that it
may be hard to uh to consider how one
would even begin to extend the testing
beyond what is standard
because you wouldn't know how to
interpret the findings even if you were
able to do the testing
overall i just think there may be a lack
of understanding of the benefit of
testing beyond that which has been in
place for some time as the standard and
the routine
so until quite recently that was the
limit of the analysis available to these
patients
and you can think about the the impact
of that lengthy diagnostic process with
no result at the end
which is clearly harmful for patients
their families and the healthcare
professionals that treat them
so it's really costly and frustrating
and it leaves patients and their
families with little information about
recurrence risk or perhaps signposting
to appropriate treatment or care and
support
so i'm just sewing on the slide there
anxiety worry and then
obviously considerations around
restricted personal care
and thinking about support groups and
even in some cases treatment efficacy
and adverse effects
so as i said at the beginning of this
introduction to the topic the diagnostic
yield using exome sequencing in a
postnatal setting
has been consistently shown to improve
the diagnostic
yield in these patients and so you can
see on the slide here just one example
of a study from a few years ago where
the yield they they found was about 40
percent
so what i now wanted to do was just
touch briefly on
exome sequencing in the prenatal setting
rather than the postnatal as
i've just been talking about so it's a
bit of a background we know that fetal
ultrasound detects anomalies in about
two to five percent of pregnancies
and these abnormalities can range from
isolated minor abnormalities to those
that may involve multiple systems and be
much more severe
another roughly 4 000 monogenic diseases
we know at least 200 of them have a
prenatal manifestation
and that list is constantly growing as
our understanding improves and
and our learning in this area increases
um but what we do know already is that
genetic disorders are a leading cause of
morbidity and premature death in the
prenatal and neonatal period
so when a case has an underlying genetic
diagnosis
it's really really important that
they're identified to allow for that
accurate management
and diagnosis is clearly also important
in terms of enabling reproductive
decision making
and also assessment of recurrence risk
for patients
so as i'm showing here current testing
strategies are only about
able to achieve a genetic diagnosis in
around 40 percent of cases
but we know that the real figure is
likely to be much higher than that so
there will be a subset of that 60
undiagnosed who do have a genetic
abnormality it's just that we can't
detect
it using the methods that we we have in
place at present
and when i think about you know current
testing strategies what i'm
considering here is qfpcr perhaps a
g-bounded carrier type and of course
microarray and there will no doubt be
other standard testing protocols that
are in place
so the yield for exome sequencing
clearly varies
uh in both the pre and the postnatal
setting depending on the
patient selection and when we think
about the prenatal setting the the
pregnancy cohort that we're looking at
and
so some studies however have suggested a
yield of up to 80
which i'm showing on the slide here but
so others have found it to be much lower
but
what i now wanted to do is just focus on
um
the exome service that we provide here
at congenica
and in particular i wanted to highlight
for you some complex cases that we've
used uh
exome sequencing to resolve
so we've been running this exome service
uh for around two years and we've had
analyzed over 600 cases and those are
both postnatal and prenatal
um this has all been done in conjunction
with
uh st george's hospital in south london
amongst other
um amongst other customers for whatever
better word
um and i wanted to particularly focus on
georgia's hospital here however because
the cases that i'll show later on in
this presentation were all referred by
them
um but as i'm showing here on the slide
so
the uh the pipeline that we use
incorporates a copy number testing
element
and it's really fantastic to be able to
offer this single comprehensive test
we've achieved this in conjunction with
our colleagues at nonicos in developing
the
xocg assay which allows for this
assessment of exome depth
on the slide here i've illustrated the
steps that i would consider to be owned
by congenica if you like and when i say
congenica i refer both to the platform
itself
and the underlying bioinformatic
pipeline but also the clinical
interpretation that myself and my
colleagues within our clinical and
scientific team
that we perform a few key features to
highlight would be as i've said the copy
number aspect by
xmcg and exome depth but also the
variant prioritization capabilities by
examizer
as well as comprehensive reference data
in the form of decipher
clinvar we also have mastermind
integrated within the product which is a
fantastic variant level literature
searching tool
um and if we think about so
what kind of results are we getting well
you can see that the vast majority of
those
634 cases are postnatal
but we do as i've said offer a rapid
service for prenatal cases
and our diagnostic yield across the
across the um patient groups across the
postnatal prenatal setting is
sits at 23 in terms of a varan
interpretation approach i don't have
time to talk about that extensively
today but i just wanted to uh to touch
on it quickly is um
we do use acmg guidelines and we
consider
standard lines of evidence when
performing our interpretations such as
functional studies and segregation
information
however what i really wanted to to point
out today is that we have a
we have a really unique set up with some
georges and that we have a
an extremely collaborative and close
working relationship with the physicians
and the whole care team
and as such we have a real depth of
phenotypic information
at our disposal and i think this has
benefited us
hugely and allowed for the upgrading or
downgrading
of variants of uncertain significance in
many many cases
so we we certainly feel it's truly worth
if possible investing in a mostly
a truly multidisciplinary approach um
just to say we do we do report variants
of uncertain significance and clearly
they can represent um
for one of a better word a burden in in
some ways so wherever possible it's good
to be able to review those and resolve
them um
either either way um i won't be talking
directly any more about the congenica
platform and its capabilities
but um i some of the cases do show some
aspects of what a powerful tool it is
in helping us to solve and these complex
and often challenging cases
so what i'm showing here is a breakdown
of the yield for postnatal cases which
stands at
21 on a previous slide i showed that
some studies have seen a yield of about
40
however it's important to note that the
yields as i've said will vary depending
upon the cohort selected
and we don't keep our referrals as such
so we see a wide range of phenotypes not
just
neurodevelopmental disorders however the
pie chart to the right
is showing that the vast majority of our
referrals um
are in patients with developmental
disorders and to the left you'll see
hopefully it's
clear enough on the sides to the left
you will see um
the diagnostic yield in this phenotypic
group so in the neurodevelopmental
disorders
compared to other phenotypic groups is
the highest
um both figures also give you an idea of
the breadth of referrals we see so we
see everything from
cardiac referrals to endocrine and
absolutely everything in between so um
and just a final note to say that we do
see mostly trios um so we do see um
but we will take uh other family
structures so singletons and
situations where you have affected
siblings we handle them
all of those so what i now wanted to do
was just to move to discussing an
interesting postnatal case with you
so this was a a patient a 13 year old
girl referred to us for investigation of
developmental delay
and an epilepsy phenotype she also has a
similarly affected sibling
um a huge amount of testing had been
undertaken
prior to this exome including enrollment
in multiple large-scale sequencing
studies such as the
100 000 genomes project here in the uk
but none of this uh none of this testing
had managed to find a cause for this
particular child's condition
so using the uh congenica platform
we were able to detect one maternally
inherited missense variant but
arguably more interestingly one
paternally
inherited synonymous variant that is
predicted to
create a cryptic splice site in the
alg-11 gene
so the phenotype of alg-11 now which is
a um congenital disorder of
glycosylation the phenotype is a good
fit for both of the affected siblings
so um there are we believe two reasons
why this finding was not detected using
any of the other
sequencing approaches that had been
performed well
firstly the biochemical screening and so
the normal biochemical screening result
that the patient had had doesn't
fit with the finding of alg 11. hence we
feel that it's possible that this
particular disorder or the possibility
of this disorder
was not flagged up for the clinician or
care team
and this really highlights the challenge
clinicians are faced
faced with around genotype phenotype
relationships and the fit of them
as i touched on in the introduction to
this and
secondly the synonymous variant was
filtered out by other bioinformatics
pipelines
um the congenica splicing annotation
capabilities which are very powerful
plus
the ability for us to really easily see
segregation data which
showed the variant was shared between
the affected siblings and that it was
paternally inherited
really brought this variant to our
attention
so if we think about what the outcome
here was well follow-up testing if the
patient
uh showed shortened alg um transcripts
um although splicing in this particular
gene is actually quite difficult to
interpret
and digging a little bit deeper into the
literature showed that normal
biochemical screening is actually often
seen in alg 11. so that fits with the um
normal iso um iso electric uh focusing
of transferrin seen in both siblings
that i mentioned earlier
um further testing is now in progress to
look for reduction of protein levels um
however the hbo lc and the thin layer
chromatography has already shown
truncated sugar structures in both of
the girls
so the finding was of great relief to
the family and we really do hope to
soon be definitively able to end the
diagnostic odyssey for them once that
follow-up testing is complete
so if we now focus our attention to the
prenatal work that we've been doing
so as i said the majority of our
referrals um are postnatal but in that
prenatal group the majority of our
referrals have actually been
from pregnancies with multiple
congenital anomalies
um with skeletal dysplasias giving the
highest yield of any phenotypic group
and that figure sits at around 69
as you can see in the graph um to the
left um
so really high um and we accept all
family structures as i said um
however the majority of our cases are
trios um
trio testing as just to touch on a
little bit further
we know that it's not always feasible or
appropriate for some families however
having parental information is really
useful in terms of the efficiency gains
to be had when looking at the mode of
inheritance for a variant
and clearly when you don't have uh
parental samples you can't determine if
a variance denovo
and this can really be an important
piece of evidence when assigning
pathogenicity
and we do find that in many cases this
this information about the de novo
status is is the difference between a
variant of uncertain significance and a
pathogenic assessment
uh i wanted to highlight the point as
well that as with post-natal
reports we do um we do report variants
of uncertain significance and
some may argue that the variant of
uncertain significance burden here is
even higher in some ways
so good to be able to remove that where
at all possible
so um of the 120 cases that we've tested
we're getting an overall yield of about
31
and this includes two cases where we've
identified a cnv of clinical
significance
so one of those copy number variants um
it's going fantastic in terms of
efficiency so thinking about time and
money saving to be able to detect
cnvs and the smvs and indels in tandem
so on to my second case study and this
is a prenatal referral
so this was a referral from an unrelated
couple who had one previous healthy
child but also a history of miscarriages
and by the 20-week scan uh short femurs
were present and a suspected fracture
although
calcification of the skull was actually
normal um
by 33 weeks however boeing of the right
female was present and there was
evidence of
further fractures so there was clearly
um a query at this stage of whether this
was an osteogenesis imperfecta
so what we did is we undertook a
singleton xn sequencing in this instance
focusing on the
osteogenesis imperfecta gene panel from
panlap which is a
genomics england curation resource um if
any of you haven't accessed panel app
before
i would really urge you to go and take a
look at it after after today and as it's
a really fantastic resource and
we do rely on one that rely on it we use
it quite heavily and along with our own
kind of assessment manual gene curation
effort but yeah really fantastic
resource
so what we found is two variants in the
alpl gene one missense and one splicing
and the splicing variants predicted to
impact the nearby donor site
this particular splicing variant has
been described in multiple affected
patients with one homozygous case being
lethal
the missense variance missense variant
had been described in the compound
head state in multiple patients but this
as i said this was the singleton case so
but without parental samples it was
really hard for us to call these
variants anything other than of
uncertain significance
now um alpl is associated with
uh defective mineralization of bone and
teeth um in the
presence in the presence of low activity
of serum and bone alkaline phosphatase
and both dominant and recessive modes of
inheritance have been described
so what we did is we followed this
testing up with parental studies to give
us both segregation data but also
looking at the biochemical result
of these in the parents testing is
unreliable in pregnant women but the
father was found to have a low alp
which is clearly consistent with the
findings as carriers would also be
protected to have low alp
and this finding actually gave a much
better prognosis than osteogenesis
imperfecta and the pregnancy continued
with the right care in place to support
the family
if we think about postnatal management
so postnatal metabolic assessment
was performed and confirmed a diagnosis
of infantile hypophosphatasium
and the skeletal survey showed uh hyper
mineralization
um the baby was started on enzyme
replacement therapy and it's clearly
fantastic when you have a finding like
this that directly impacts the
management in this case in such a
positive way we feel
the couple themselves could then have
follow-up about recurrence risk but also
appropriate management as carriers
themselves may develop symptoms so
overall this was a really fantastic
result for this family um from what
started out as some some pretty
tough uh tough scans
for the final case i wanted to discuss a
prenatal uh
prenatal test where we detected both a
copy number variant and a single
nucleotide variant in parallel
so if we think about the standard
sequential testing pathway in a prenatal
setting for a moment
there are really two scenarios so
firstly you may have a microarray or
other copy number assessment may be
performed and give a negative result
which then
prompts an assessment by exome or other
ngs testing to look for single
nucleotide variants
secondly you may have an exome performed
that doesn't have a copy number
assessment element to it and the exome
detects a single smv so a single hit
if you like in a recessive condition and
what you would then have to do is follow
this up with
mlpa or some other copy number testing
to search for the second tip
and both of these approaches are um
timely and
you know yeah and clearly in a prenatal
referral uh
this is time sensitive and there's also
a cost implication so being able to
provide a single test is something
that we're really really excited about
um being able to do
so this was the case referred at 20
weeks with multiple abnormalities but
primarily this was a uh a hydropic
picture
you can see from the scans i'm showing
on the slide here the bright bowel and
pleural effusions to the left
and the raised nucleon right and there
was also some right ventricular
brightness and hypertrophy as well which
i haven't got the scan up there
so what we found is we detected both a
maternally inherited frameshift variant
and a paternally inherited copy number
loss in the sump
1 gene now zamf1 is associated with
autosomal recessive multiple sulfur
taste deficiency
and you can see on the slide just a
snapshot of the congenica integrated
genome browser where we actually perform
our interpretation and analysis so just
to give you an idea
of how that looks pulling in the
functional and reference data amongst
other information to come to that
pathogenicity conclusion
uh cases of severe neonatal multiple
sulfates deficiency presenting in the uh
with high drops in the prenatal period
have been described
um another important uh important point
for this case was we were made aware
that array cgh testing actually hadn't
detected this copy number loss
um the copy number loss was about 69
kilobases in size
so while we aren't able to say
definitively what this may be suggesting
is that exome sequencing can detect copy
number variants that microarray can't
what i've also shown on the slide here
is the turnaround time of 20 days from
sample receipt to
report and this is really reflective of
our standard turnaround time
so just just uh i don't have a slide on
this but actually i just wanted to talk
about another case that we had that we
detected both the pathogenic snv and cnv
um again both inherited from a
non-affected parent in the rbm
8a gene and this was a fetus with a
skeletal dysplasia phenotype
including a short humerus and
abnormalities of the right arm
and we found the um well characterized
five prime utr variant associated with
thrombocytopenia absent radius syndrome
um
associated with a copy number loss of
about i think it was about 400 kilobases
that encompassed the rbm 8a gene um and
in this case we later found consistency
with the array finding so the array had
was able to detect the loss and however
the point i was making about
illustrating this case was that that
case
also had a 20-day turnaround time so
this is fairly reflective of the time
we're managing to meet for these
georgia's prenatal referrals and we're
really we're really proud of that um
in terms of you know offering management
time in a timely manner for these for
these patients
so to conclude i hope today i've given
an insight into the challenge of
diagnosing rare disease patients and how
exome sequencing can be of benefit to
balance cost
clinical utility and diagnostic yield
i really hope the case studies i've
presented have been of interest to you
i think they highlight the challenges of
phenotype genotype correlations in rare
disease amongst other challenges
um but mainly i really hope that they
show how exome sequencing is
already being used clinically to end the
diagnostic odyssey and benefit patients
with rare disease
so just a big thank you to my clinical
colleagues at st george's
as i said whose cases these were and the
scientific colleagues that we have there
who help us with this work
and in particular to my colleagues at
congenica um without whom this this
testing um would not be possible
um so if you'd like to find more about
about the work that we do and what we do
or further information about the
congenica platform in general and and
how we might work
uh work with you please do get in touch
the contact details are there on the
slide
and i'm also always really happy to take
questions directly as well so
thank you so much for your time today
it's been a real pleasure to be able to
show this work to